[Music]
[Music]
welcome to looper i'm brian rubin
today we're talking all about the marvel
cinematic universe
you know the mcu has brought us some
legendary villains over the last 10
years or so
agatha harkness kilma and of course
the big purple guy thanos the mcu has
also brought us some less legendary bad
guys
guys like yellowjacket malekith and gary
shandling
i'm joined today by tom and nina to try
and answer the question
who are the best and worst villains the
marvel cinematic universe could
introduce in phase four
tom nina hello hey how are you
are you implying that gary shandling is
any of us
i'm just saying that as far as a villain
is concerned
not the top-tier bad guy kind of
thing i love gary shandling but
is he anyway you know what i don't know
did you ever see mixed
got some darkness dude
rest in peace so tom tom
who are the best and worst villains that
marvel can introduce in phase four
you know i'm glad that you asked that
brian because i was thinking about this
just the other night
while i was writing down ideas you told
me yeah
[Music]
who are the best and worst feelings that
we could bring back into the mc
personally i think uh like in terms of
the best uh
and what makes a good villain i mean is
there an objective answer but uh
vincent not for you from daredevil that
would be like my uh
my my my number one topic if we could
bring one guy back like the intensity
that that guy brought to the role
just spectacular practically alien
myself
so you're you're thinking about villains
that could come
back into the mcu is that that's where
we're going
i don't know have we determined whether
or not we're clowning netflix as uh
stuff that happened oh that's a good
that's a good point netflix is
definitely stuff that happened my
particular question here was what
villains could they bring into the mcu
from the comics but
i think it's totally valid to ask what
villains that we've had before
could come back to all all of all
villains
are on the table as long as they are
marvel villains so in terms of like
fresh to the mcu i uh
at a very personal level i would love to
see sentinels pop up at some point
uh those were those were one of the
first like terrifying nightmares that i
remember having as a kid
it was like those big purple that get
the things around i
i would love to uh before i die i would
love to see suddenly done right on the
big screen
just like giant terrifying
robot monsters are you in favor of a
master mold perhaps
uh i don't know if it's dark and raised
i'd say go get it checked out but
[Laughter]
master mold of course is the giant mama
sentinel that makes
the big sentinels but they're it's baby
sentinels so mastermold is a classic
x-men villain don't talk to me like
people that don't know mastery
i know you know master mold i'm trying
to explain who mastermold
we're trying to translate tom yes so
anyway so you want to see the sentinels
you want to see vincent d'onofrio tell
us more about
the villains you'd like to see my only
other like big one
the thing is there's a there's a caveat
and i'd like to come back around toward
a bit
i feel like we've got to see galactus at
some point right
yeah i mean that's that's i think so
yeah it's kind of one of the last like
really big recognizable way over-the-top
villains that marvel hasn't uh hasn't
really
touched too much well we know that they
haven't been able to touch galactus
because
up until very recently galactus as a
member of the fantastic four
cast of characters he's a fantastic four
villain first and foremost
marvel studios hasn't had the rights to
use galactus because they were owned by
fox now marvel
disney owns fox and so that opens things
up for guys like the sentinels who were
also x-men also owned by fox for the
movie rights
now sentinels now uh galactus are both
available to come into the marvel
universe i
100 agree galactus was on my list that
you know you can see he's
right there above my head watching over
all of us galactus my friend my best
friend i like to think he always is
yeah yeah tom do you want to explain who
galactus is and just what his deal is
well i'm glad that you asked brian uh
you know the song food glorious food
from the oliver musical he's that but
he's a person
he is a uh semi-timeless entity from
a uh universe that they get destroyed
before ours was ever created he's like
all that's left of this other universe
and he loves eating planets man
he's all about eating planet he loves
two things he loves a good helmet
and he loves a delicious planted
sandwich i like how his helmet has a
little brim on it
on the front yeah like a little baseball
cap but
why also like the little
little mask i think that's my favorite
part is he's got like the little
dominoes
just to protect his identity his
original design
his original design he had a big belt
with a g on it and bikes yeah he did
and short shots nice shorts they're
making a comeback so that could work
out in the outer reaches of space yeah
you would know this if you ever watched
80 sci-fi
true true did you have any other
villains for your list tom
uh not for the best ones no okay nina
what about your best villain that the
mcu could bring
in in phase four so i've only got the
one
uh and while i was doing research for
this i stumbled on her and i wasn't that
familiar so i did some research at
so i stumbled upon amora also known as
the
enchantress who's a thor villain yes uh
and she is cool and like i really loved
cate blanchett's hella like i really
love a good female antagonist
uh and she sounds awesome and i think
that like
having chris hemsworth have a really
seductive
villain to play off of could be
tremendously fun especially if takeaway
tt keeps directing thor movies
so i have the worst news nina
they they kind of they they did that on
agents of [ __ ] didn't they bring her in
and agents of shield oh i didn't was
there a chance
on agents of shield i think she was an
agent of shield and she got the whole
like power rangers treatment that that
show gave so many
i think no i don't think you're right i
i i could be wrong we're going to look
this up in a fight i would love to be
wrong
i think it was a different please be
wrong because i was really jazzed about
this
i think it was a different character
from the comics that was
enchantress adjacent if i recall
correctly
i will admit it's been a long time since
i've watched agents of shield
i will also admit i didn't finish agents
of shield
nobody did man
yeah i forgot that it was a show
to be honest until right now when you
said agents of shield
i want to i'm not yeah i'm i'm almost
positive it was a
different character that wasn't quite
the enchantress but she did basically
everything the enchantress did
but with that said but let's but let's
also be real here though right even if
agents of shield did do that they also
did the inhumans
and then they made an inhuman show
anyway right that's true that was
totally different and divorced from
everything happening
right and if we're talking vincent
d'onofrio then we can talk the
enchantress too i think that's fair game
they could just
they could just say it was a different
enchantress it was a different
incarnation of brain changes if they
even acknowledge that it happened on
agents of shield at all so far the only
acknowledgement of anything that
happened on agents of shield
in the movies was the inclusion of tv
jarvis
from the peggy carter
oh that's it yeah because he's great
that's true
that's true so there's room for
enchantress i love the enchanter she's a
great villain
she's great yeah like reading more about
her i was like trying to think of like
who would play her like uh you know just
trying to like
like maybe not the right age but like a
laura dern type would be kind of really
fun and campy in that role
laura would be great yeah my mind went
to january jones
oh your mind always goes to january
no that's good every month of the year
when she's given like
room to play around in a role like on
last man on earth she really has a good
time so she's
so fun she's so good and if she's
allowed to let loose and just be weird
and fun yes she could be
amazing she wasn't very good as emma
frost but no one was good
in that movie which was which movie was
that no that was first class
that was first class first class let me
back up
some people were good in that movie she
didn't really have much to do because
like
severe and now we're closed yes that's
true yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna walk back my
statement slagging off all of the first
class yes it was so i'm gonna
i'm gonna fan casting chances too i'm
gonna pick january jones
with an assist from you and i'm gonna
say her you've got it
it's yours yeah she's as good as cast
perfect somebody call marvel like
whoever plays her as long as she keeps
her uh
the same pants that she had back in the
day i don't think like her original
costume
the best paint i mean like we we can go
on
uh galactus pants enchantress's pants
very fancy fancy green pants in my shoes
fanciest pants they were
they had little loopies on them so
my pick not that either of you asked
um is
i was i came armed with with two because
i thought someone might say one of them
and i was right so tom said galactus
my pick is doctor doom who
up until now also was a fantastic four
villain
so off limits to marvel studios has
appeared in two different iterations of
the fantastic four franchise
both times not the best
let's walk these words back man let's
not say things that we can't take back
you're a big fan of the depiction of of
doctor doom in one of the previous
fantastic four movies
this might just you know what this is
this is a me thing i don't want to bring
me things into it
i i don't hate the first two the uh the
ones from
like the mid-2000s
not great i'm not going to say good
i'm not going to say good but you're not
going to go that far you're just going
to
lightly defend okay i'm going to i'm
going to i'm going to
prod at defending the uh my issue with
the doctor doom
realization in those movies specifically
is that
it's only a fraction of the kind of
great stuff you can do with a guy like
doctor doom
totally you know so like even if the
actor portraying him did a good job with
the material and there are definitely
things in those two fantastic four
movies and even the
the josh trank one there's stuff in
those movies that i think
are cool they're good they're
interesting chris evans as the human
torch was actually
really excellent when he was cast as
captain america i was like
that's great this guy can can act he's
awesome
so um dr doom that actor
whose name escapes me he's
he's fine for that movie but overall
what i want out of a doctor doom
is a uh and totally uh ego maniacal
uh machiavellian ruler of
a european country named latviria that's
always
weirdly like stuck in the dark ages and
always all the villagers have pitchforks
and torches at any moment
what is with that yeah that's what it
looks like there
that's what it is i never thought about
that but yeah no you're right the
villagers always look like
they're stuck in a medieval caste system
and that's what he likes
they also have robots that are
indiscernible from living beings
yeah and they he has a whole army of
doombots that are just
that like like marvel comics has made an
industry out of explaining away
inconsistencies with his character by
saying oh well that was a doombot that
thought it was the real doctor doom
i'm the real doctor doom um so there's
so much room for mistakes
exactly you can do whatever you want and
then this is the character that you want
to bring into the mc of the mobster
what i like about him what i like about
him is that he is
so purely and deliciously
into his thing he's
he's the hero of his own story and he is
the most
heroic hero he has uh what what's called
main character syndrome right where
you're like i am the protagonist
yeah whenever dude shows up yeah
whenever doctor doom shows up the story
gets better
whenever the heroes have to fight dr
doom it's a great
story it doesn't matter what dr doom is
doing he's just
fun he's he just improves the the
material he's just so great
i just love the way he refers to himself
in the third person again these are
things that don't necessarily have to
come to the movie but i do think that
they're
that if you can if you can make a guy
like iron man believable and interesting
and entertaining you can make a guy like
dr doom
threatening and yet still entertaining
he can have that
that charisma that ego and still
be a menacing bad guy if anyone can do
it marvel studios can do it so i want so
who who do you want playing doctor doom
who has that level of charisma
i saw somebody fan cast giancarlo
esposito and i thought that was pretty
spot-on
that's pretty good that would be
actually fantastic i don't know if he
wants to spend his entire life playing
like enigmatic largely silent villains
but if he doesn't
i think that's kind of his thing yeah
but that's a perfect cast like i didn't
even
like i didn't have an answer ready but
as soon as you said that i was like yep
that'll work
yeah that would be great i'd pay big
money for that yeah who has the charisma
to play galactus we never got around to
that
another good question i wish i thought
of the casting aspect of this
yeah who has the charisma to play
galactus
that's what i'm asking you brian
so like how funny is galactus is he
funny no he's a hoot
are you kidding me he's always like i'm
hungry
he's very pretentious he's always very
like
um gosh i mean you know that's a that's
the kind of question that's really
difficult to answer because
if you had said who should play thanos
you never would have said no josh bro
right
like i don't know right like that's an
insane
it's an insane answer and frankly the
thanos that we got in the movies is
pretty different from the thanos from
the comics so that's
that's a good point you know whatever
they do with him they'll do something
good
i mean you know part of me wants to say
josh brolin because he's already been a
great thanos so he could probably do a
good galactus but that would be silly
um what about john cena sure why not oh
just give it to the rock let the rocket
launch yeah
can you smell what galactus is cooking
because he's so hungry because he's
hungry yeah i love this
i think that's the answer i think we've
come up with it who would be the worst
villains
that marvel could bring into mcu phase
four
nina so i have two
um one of them is egg head uh a
character i didn't know existed who is
just like
a a kind of like quiet
dweeby sort of person who
uh is from the ant-man comics i believe
he gets
like he gets pretty murdered pretty
quickly
uh by hawkeye and like bury the lead
nina what does his head look like
he's just called egghead because he
likes studying that's it
that's not
yeah um and then the other one i found
which is just
horrifying is carlos cabrera or gamecock
who is a chicken man that fights captain
america
shut your mouth what no it's real how
did i not know about this
i don't know he is a minor antagonist in
the captain america comics
uh yeah his name is gamecock and he's a
chicken man
i can say it seems unlikely that they're
going to bring
gamecock it seems like that they're
going to bring back
the leaper and decided but like here we
are yeah i guess you're right
you never you don't so don't count out
gamecock
i don't want to see that i would prefer
to count it out
um yeah i went looking i went poking
through like marvel dot com and all this
stuff and i just saw a chicken man and
was like that can't be good
and i did some research and yeah
in fact he is a chicken man he fights
captain america unsuccessfully a couple
of times i don't want to
i don't want to see any part of that i
don't want to see like a falcon chicken
fight oh he he didn't win
yeah no in a shocking turn of events the
chicken man didn't beat america's
superhero i know it's
weird telling me the chicken boy tried
to fight
the leader of the avenger that didn't
that didn't did not go
did not end well for him yeah
yeah so those are those are my picks i'm
talking pretty good about them
tom who would be your worst villain to
add to the mcu phase four
i'm gonna make a uh
i'm gonna make a difficult call here
okay
galactus okay please explain
you gotta hurt brian's feelings so hey i
hurt my own feelings too i'm so excited
to see galactic i would love to see
black he was on my list of the best
characters to bring in
the problem that i think we're going to
run into at this point is that we're
running out of like
recognizable like back in the day comic
book characters
you know what i mean like they're we're
down to like half of the original
avengers
maybe two two out of six something like
that some uh yeah
i just i don't know if it's gonna have
the same gravitas if you if you bring in
great big bucket-headed planet eater guy
and then
like the only people that you have left
to fight him are like
white vision
well don't forget now hang on though
i'm gonna i'm gonna subvert this though
right but
galactus doesn't have to just fight the
avengers galactus is a fantastic four
villain and we know what it is
a fantastic four movie at the end of
phase four so if you
tell me that you're gonna introduce a
fantastic four movie and then at the end
of that movie you don't have a tease for
galactus is coming and that's our big
arc over the next several years to
prepare for the coming of galactus
i would love to believe that you're
right brian but at the same time like we
said through all of one division
at the end what that was leading to
was bonus she was really yeah reading
r.i.p ralph boner yeah gone but not
forgotten
i do feel a little bit like maybe maybe
kevin's messing with us now
like maybe he he got through the main
story that he wanted to tell and despite
having a stable of characters that would
absolutely carry the franchise for
another 20 years maybe at this point
he's just like
he's reached the point of his career
where he's okay with just kind of
nah he's just winging it now he's just
coasting for the next
25 years dr bond here comes doctor
dr bong is a howard the duck villain
untenable storylines from like the early
2000s i want to say
just go wait until you're not on your
work computer and go look it up it's
amazing
oh man so uh my pick for
worst villain that they could possibly
introduce is another old fantastic four
villain
um he goes by the trapster but his
original name
tom you're you look very excited you
know who i'm sure
is this piece by pete it's pace podcast
pace poppy oh
i stumbled across pace pop pete as well
so pace pop pete
carries a bucket of glue
and he shoots the glue with his blue gun
and he fights the human torch
and it's a close one it's close the
human torch
almost doesn't win basically just like
a mom who shops at marshalls for like
it's really good glue
it's really a good glue at marshalls i
love the
defense of galactus was we're gonna
bring in the fantastic four but 25
of that team just almost got taken out
by glue by a glue guy
yeah well it's fireproof glue that's why
oh well if it's fireproof by themselves
okay
stupid it was tough it was tough so yeah
so so the back story on pace pop pete is
apparently he was a brilliant scientist
who developed a
super duper effective awesome glue but
instead of
saying like i should be in business i
should do
things with my glue that are businessy
he says i'm going to rob a bank and then
i'm going to try to steal a missile
and luckily for the bank torch was
online
to access his savings account that day
so as it happened the two of them
tussled and after he
defeated pace pot pete he forever
harbored a grunge
a grudge excuse me against the human
torch
and there we go eventually he changed
his name to the trapster
he still shoots glue out of his gloves
so he changed his name not his gimmick
he was like this is working great but i
think he does this
isn't the glue the problem is the uh
appearance the presentation it's the
branding
right so anyway yeah i feel like that
would be maybe not the best choice
for no that would i would not want to
see that
there's that i love that taste popped
pete
thanks for joining us please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single